[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with the
announcement today that Kevin Feige will
be developing a Star Wars film for
Disney things look bleak for spider-man
with it looking less and less likely
that he will be back in the MCU anytime
soon
now if you've been keeping up to date
with the channel you'll know that we've
been referring to Tom Holland as
Schrodinger's spider just for the sheer
amount of times that he's in and out
this is pretty much the movie equivalent
of the hokey cokey and in light of the
recent news I thought I'd take a step
back way of the entire situation and
give my thoughts on everything there's
so many rumors and false reports flying
about at the moment that I'm purely
going to stick to the facts with this so
we can get a clearer picture of exactly
what's going on whilst I am giving my
thoughts on the situation this is back
to purely by official statements instead
of just being from we've got this
covered
now flash back to what feels like a
lifetime ago and we got the announcement
that negotiations between Disney and
Sony were a standstill and that
Spiderman had been removed from the
co-ownership that had gone on since his
appearance in civil war at d23 both
Kevin Feige and Tom Holland stated that
they were happy with the opportunities
that they'd been given but that going
forward the character would be solely
under Sony now a big factor in this
dissolving of the contract was that
Kevin Feige was focused on other
projects at Disney and that he didn't
have time to work alongside Sony Studios
for the 5% revenue share that Disney was
getting under the old contract in light
of today's news I think it's clear that
Disney agreed that Feige would work on
Star Wars and this is why he was unable
to divide his time further days after
d23 Holland announced that he would
indeed be in spider-man 3 and that he
had discussed the idea with Sony and
that they were going forward with the
project
since then Sony CEO Tony Vince acara
stated that the door was currently
closed but that going forward there may
be an opportunity to work together one
small cut to today and if you stand back
and look at
thing I think it's pretty clear what's
been going on Disney no doubt wanted
Feige to basically come in and save Star
Wars and that's the idea of him giving
up a large wealth of his time for
spider-man just didn't seem right
decisions like the announcement today
are made months in advance before they
ever see the light of day in the press
and I think it's pretty clear that Feige
had agreed to do Star Wars Sony wish to
have him still giving the same amount of
time that he had in the past and thus
negotiations fall apart looking at
things as a whole I think it's extremely
unlikely that spider-man will be back in
the MCU for spider-man 3 I personally
think that Sony know that the door is
always open for them at Disney and they
want to take the property develop their
own thing that ties into their venom
verse and then if things don't go
according to plan they can always return
and renegotiate with the studio in order
to put things back to how they were now
whilst the studio's may be working
separately I still personally believe
that spider-man 3 will at least in name
only be connected to the MCU
you simply cannot take characters from
one universe and completely detach them
from their roots like this and thus the
smart thing to do would be for
spider-man to go on the run pay lip
service to things that have already
happened but branch off in a new
direction now will this still mean that
it's connected to the MCU even though
the character is no longer under the
Disney umbrella technically yes and this
could potentially be enough to keep fans
interested this is pretty much the
equivalent of taking say a character
like Michael Myers making a new horror
franchise at another studio with him
that doesn't have Laurie Strode in but
as the character himself still
originates from the universe it will be
possible for fans Minds to make it so
that there is still a connection even if
behind the scenes things are not in
writing now as for Disney and Sony
looking at things purely from a legal
standpoint the two companies will still
have to negotiate over certain things as
has been ongoing ever since the
character was bought by Sony several
decades ago this is because Mar will
still use the character in merchandise
comic books cartoons and so on and thus
there will always be a relationship
between Sony and Marvel as they will
have to meet in order to discuss certain
directions and so on so there is still
until that at some point the two studios
could once again decide that it's time
to put spider-man back under the fold of
the MCU as I've no doubt that these two
corporations are in regular contact with
one another however for the meantime I
personally do believe that at least for
spider-man 3 that the wall crawler will
be at Sony and thus they will be going
forward trying to begin their
spider-verse
they already have several TV shows and
venom sequel greenlit as well as the
möbius movie next year so this seems
like their main focus at the moment I
could be wrong
100 percent 110 percent even which means
I could take away how wrong I am by 10
percent and still be 100 percent wrong I
don't know you do the math on that one
but I will of course keep everyone up to
date with the rumors reports and other
behind-the-scenes info that hits the
internet about spider-man but in the
meantime I thought I'd just give
everyone an update on how I feel while
Sidhu still need to discuss the Apple
Sony situation properly at the moment
I'm just viewing that as a rumor and I
wanted to keep this video to the
official stories and statements so that
we don't get bogged down in intellectual
property law now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this do you think
this whole Star Wars situation has been
what's really been the factor behind the
negotiations falling apart and if
possible do you think spider-man will
return to the MCU comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of the Kevin Feige
story itself would you be linked at the
end I'll go over everything you need to
know about it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to come chat to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
topics so hopefully I see you over there
after this well so just wanna let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the Sony Disney situation in the
comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you